this is what is left of a coronavirus
testing center in the suburbs of you
Google mobile phone footage captures
people destroying the makeshift center
built to check them for the virus scared
and angry they strip it bare riots
continued through the next morning with
police firing tear gas to disperse a
growing and anxious crowd many say they
want the center to be built outside of
their neighborhood this woman shouts we
are humans we don't want the coronavirus
here right where we live we don't want
it today or tomorrow she says with more
than 300 confirmed cases in ivory coast
the virus is spreading rapidly the
government has imposed a lockdown on the
economic capital a Bijan and the
nationwide curfew measures that come too
late says local authorities who fear
many more people are infected without
knowing there wasn't kpop some of you
will have a fever this evening or even
earlier others will golf or have a sore
throat others will feel strange don't
worry all the districts of Abidjan will
have these centers in place to
facilitate and provide information it's
not just for testing it's to provide
information this crisis is revealing the
level of distrust people have for their
government and health services Ivorian
football star Didier Drogba
took to social media after two French
doctors one of whom has the Anstey to
pester in lille suggested testing of
kovat 19 vaccine on africans the
institut pasteur has more than 11
centres of research in africa including
in ivory coast which are used to detect
viruses many people living in ubu ghouls
say they don't want to be guinea pigs in
experiments involving a virus they
believe comes from Europe I don't think
this place is appropriate because it's
an illness and we know how it spreads so
if we need to set up a hospital of this
kind they should put it outside the city
the government is seeking to reassure
people saying that no testing will be
carried out on patients but with cases
multiplying fear of the virus along with
the virus itself seems to be growing
uncontrollably Nicholas Hawke al-jazeera